what's your process for developing
characters how do you go about it well a
character kind of develops itself and
which you need to so basically what you
do when you're dealing with that is
you're kind of like a checklist rather
than you're developing the character
you're let the velvet character develop
himself but you you say you know what
she has to have the the following thing
she has to have what's her problem you
know for example is that clear because
if that's not clear your story's not
gonna hook the audience and what's her
you know what's her problem
interfering with I called this mission
in life like usually it's her motivation
in the story
their problem is interfering with her
mission life you know she's somebody who
wants to become a nurse but something
via what happens in the opening scene
that seems to make her if you want to
save this person you have to do
something violent back and therefore her
motivation if she's going to save this
person interferes with her mission those
are two kind of part of parts of the
checklist and you go on to talk about
how does she change this is called her
arc you know what is the arc of her
change how is she different at the end
of the story because a lot of times we
are covering stories you know they're
submitted to us when we go well you know
the characters don't change she's
exactly the way she was at the end she
is at the beginning so why do we we
don't get off on that you know we don't
we're not satisfied by a story where the
characters don't change so these are
kinds of checklist that you apply to
characters once you get get them going
starting with that intriguing situation
and then adding along the way to you
know but by just checking them against
traditional characters that work well
you